sont aux aguets à Pékin, tandis
qu'à Shanghai, des barrières
ont été installées. La Chine
anticipe d'autres manifestations
comme celles qui ont secoué
le pays ces derniers jours.
"Abat Xi Jinping!", scandent
ces manifestants. La colère
contre le président semble
atteindre des sommets.
Un incendie mortel dans
la province du Xinjang a mis
le feu aux poudres. Des Chinois
estiment que la politique
zéro-COVID de Pékin a ralenti
les secours et demandent
un relâchement des mesures
sanitaires.
(cris de la foule)
GUY SAINT-JACQUES, ancien
ambassadeur du Canada en Chine,
- Il y a pas eu de
manifestations de cette ampleur-
là dans autant de villes depuis,
je dirais, les événements de
juin 1989, alors qu'il y avait
eu le massacre àacacacace
Tiananmen à Pékin.
BEI SHAN, journaliste indép.,
originaire Shanghai
- Shanghai, c'est un endroit
plus démocratique que les autres
régions en Chine.
- Cette Montréalaise,
arrivée au pays en 2014 a
grandi à Shanghai, où elle
était journaliste. Elle
affirme n'avoir jamais vu
de manifestation du genre
dans sa ville natale.
- Je pense que c'est très
nouveau pour les Chinois qui
vont manifester dans la rue.
- Ceux, qui comme elle, veulent
visiter de la famille en Chine,
doivent se soumettre à plusieurs
jours, voire plusieurs semaines
d'isolement. Si bien qu'elle a
abandonné l'idée d'y aller pour
l'instant.
- On comprend pas pourquoi
les autres pays, on a déjà fait
les règlements différents pour
COVID, mais enn n n n n insiste
encore qu'il faut vraiment
zéro COVID.
- D'autant plus que
les restrictions pèsent
sur l'économie chinoise.
- L'économie va mal,
particulièrement le secteur
immobilier, ça fait que tout
ça mis ensemble fait que
Xi Jinping se retrouve devant
une tempête presque parfaite.
- Pékire choix que
de faire des concessions,
croit cet expert.
ANDRÉ LALIBERTÉ, prof. étud
politiques à l'U Ottawa
- Mais je pense pas, en passant,
je pense pas que ça va mener
à un changement de régime hein,
il faut s'entendre. Parce qu'il
y a pas d'alternative politique
au Parti communist